today we are playing rocket league
because rocky league is now free to play
that's what we're playing it's free
nothing's better than free we will be
playing three games and every time
someone scores a goal on us we each have
to eat a jalapeno what oh that's gonna
be a lot if 10 goals are scored on us at
the end of the video we each have to eat
10 jalapenos oh
stop carl you got to carry i'm really
not that good hey boys boys you know
they're saying teamwork we're eating
eating jalapenos oh joining whoo
all right let's do it all right okay
stay back for now stay back for now nope
going in i'm going in hot going in hot
what'd i say you guys stay with me
no no no no i'm in goal don't worry your
boy's got it okay i got defense you guys
push up everybody else let's go i missed
it this game's hard hit a car we don't
need to eat jalapenos wait what happens
if we score uh nothing if you've never
played rocket league the point is to
keep the ball out of your goal oh you
guys hit it straight towards that was
not me that was i think that was jimmy
that was not me oh wait i thought you
were in the van jimmy i am baby oh you
didn't hit it and hit it in
i missed it this is hard got it got it
it's on their side it's on their side
still come on boys teamwork it's just
coming in hot i'm coming hot
boom oh i just slammed into the wall oh
no no no
get in there
no jalapeno
nice shot nice shot nice shot
nice shot oh i'm staying defense
oh
my god
yeah that was easy this kid's bad hey
i'm pushing up i'm going up
boom yes sir chris is actually good at
this game i like this i'm on it i'm on
it
middle
i'm getting in their head guys i'm
getting in their head run up go forward
go forward go forward and go forward go
forward go forward go forward jimmy you
were supposed to be the one
you got a car you got it
oh yes
keeping us from eating a jalapeno what a
team player he is
pushing up i'll just steal the ball
because i don't care sets up a good shot
no one's there come on hit it in
boom no i hope they don't have to eat
jalapenos yeah if they they're gonna
have to eat a lot of jalapeno oh there's
a good oh beautiful shot whoever that
was good
got it got it
that was beautiful
oh my god watch this watch this watch
this club simply get set up better boom
oh we both we both went for it i hit you
into the ball to hit the ball so so far
no one has any jalapenos nope let's go
oh i missed it i'm getting in their head
yeah you go carl i said when are we done
playing against tutorial bots
oh i missed that completely oh i missed
it oh my god this is so high
my bad got it i flung it back oh oh give
me that give it oh my god 30 seconds
remaining boys don't let them score
don't let them rather not eat a jalapeno
yeah don't let them score we don't have
to win here hey don't worry about
scoring just don't get scored on but
also score to like yeah but score you
know what i'm saying
hit that hit that we got it we got here
i undershot it ah no
it's fine it's fine we win let's go yes
we are good hey watch this guys watch
the screen watch the screen
it's ready up let's go again this is fun
if you like what you're seeing click the
epic games link in the description i'm
in their goal yes yes
yes yes
i'm insane i'm trying to do the address
sorry i'm just too good this game is so
much fun click the link in description
sign in or create an epic games account
and then pick which platform you want to
play on play on any platform they're all
great did you know that rocking league
is now free on the epic game store
switch xbox and playstation it's free
everywhere everywhere i'm coming to you
i'm coming
this game is so much fun carl i love
your chat
also if you want to support me and the
boys when buying anything on rocket
league use creator code mister bees
here's the deal 100 of all the revenue i
get from my creator go yes let's go i'm
trying to play i'm sorry we just can't
stop too good 100 of the revenue
generated off my creator code i will
split between those three mobs oh cool
our moms are getting money thanks mom if
we make ten thousand dollars off the
creator codes all three of your moms get
thirty three hundred bucks oh dude
really so if you enjoy rocket league cop
the battle pass
boom that was perfect placement
i missed
now oh oh my god what were you saying
i'm sorry
sorry jimmy what are you saying you guys
wait until i start doing a talking point
to school i think he gives us motivation
with rocky league now being free to play
there are all sorts of crazy new
challenges so oh no way
why are we so good at this including an
updated challenge system the ability to
do tournaments oh and cross-platform
play and so much more i'm kind of
worried we're playing against bots i
think we're literally playing the worst
gamers in the world yeah are these even
gamers or these just moms that finished
knitting and needed something to do boom
perfect setup perfect setup for gold mid
mid mid mid mid mid i i was on the
ceiling upside down let's put this to
the test let's not move okay i'm not
moving i don't want to eat a jalapeno
i blocked it
wait guys look look at where the ball is
oh my god oh no
no you're kidding wait no they got to be
idiots they just rolled it don't hit the
ball just reverse right into our goal
reverse reverse
okay they got one so we'll eat one
hollow so they are actually really humid
okay i just had to do a human check wait
let's do it one more time one more time
no stop one more time i hate spicy stuff
they're actually trying all right
secretly i just wanted all of you to
have to eat two jalapenos oh let's
destroy no more playing around chris is
done no more afk we angry good trap oh i
said oh here it is set up
no i couldn't get there in time
i used all my boost
boom i'll just score that you mind if i
score that it was a great setup look at
this good touch
oh no i missed oh my gosh go chris go go
chris
all right carl all right carl that what
we're doing
oh i was off my trajectory was off don't
worry carl we'll just we'll just score
all the goals while you just sit in the
back of the map doing nothing so okay
yeah i won't play defense anymore i mean
do we even need these oh that's a what i
haven't seen the ball go back there once
since i've been playing we actually set
afk they still managed to score on
themselves thank you for the setup thank
you i missed it good game gg you're back
oh you hit the ball
let's
go oh yeah yeah
chick chat chick chat chick chat what'd
you say i said you guys want to start
playing now
come on boys get some more boost i got
defense i got defense don't worry about
defense i'm just getting boost middle
okay come back come back set it in got
it got it go up go up go
somebody set me up up right here right
here it's my moment my mom had to shine
set me up hit it hit it hit it towards
oh my god yes they scored on themselves
you guys are so bad it's overwhelming
look at that one man team score right
here
easy easy easy easy
all right let's do it again let's do it
again
oh oh oh
oh
he went back oh guys get it away i'm
scared oh i'm insane i'm insane no
jalapenos no jalapenos for the boys
middle head middle
we're not that bad carl i'm going for
gold go go go go go go go go go go no
oh
you hit the crossbar nice nice nice
please stop
we're just too good
oh
what's that come on sorry man reset mid
finish it yes sir oh they're literally
setting it up for us i missed they
literally are if we weren't so bad oh it
locks on the ball oh that's clutch i got
it
good pass good pass basket pass could
pass no i hit it and hit it hard
yeah that's a pass back to the d i'm
setting it up finish it finish it oh
that would have been
perfect jimmy punch it punch it punch it
punch it oh
he's about to jump on him
you got it you got it you got it
jalapeno get that mess out of here one
minute remaining oh god jalapeno
no no no no jalapenos here no carl watch
out it's coming floating oh you're only
hope no jalapenos
boom hit it back get it back this is
what i was born for
oh
would you all say that was pretty fun
that was yes that was epic let's go eat
jalapenos
less fun less fun these things are hot
and big don't take that out of context
oh we're going we're just doing it
ow
what do you mean it's not hot oh my god
it's getting pretty hot yeah my mouth
hurts
earth weren't hot oh my god my throat
burns
there's no way you're doing this
oh subscribe oh
oh